oh it's so boring without any friends
but wait a minute let's do some [ __ ]
agree to this just like hey show up in
my house hey you wanna record a video
sure let's go don't make my person
god damn hey let's do no it's not okay I
challenge you
jacksepticeye to a bottle flip challenge
we have foot cat three two one go okay
but here's the thing there's a twist
okay twist there's twice spotless you
know do it the bottle flip first you
have to pick I read it fifty P oh no 50
50 50 50 more like eighty twenty but
still there fifty fifty and you guys at
home you get to watch anyway okay let's
go down where let's go down to camera
number two okay okay camera number two
here we go
my goddamn camera number one hello hello
[ __ ] weird okay are you just gonna
pick a random you have to go I go I'm
going from the top okay what fetus on
ground after crash with pregnant woman I
don't believe that's a thing okay or I
don't believe that's a thing or a photo
of quintuplets in the uterus I don't
want to see either of their why am I
still looking at this you can look away
just by your reaction here I go
oh that's nice disgusting get that [ __ ]
away I got you I'm not back to camera
currently I am mean shut the [ __ ] up oh
my god I was looking at his videos okay
okay alright it's time for my punishment
train runs over a parked car that's
pretty cool I mean it's a it's a carer
man demonstrates some very impressive
green screen action oh it's just a video
of me oh no I got the car won the video
yeah it's a Jif
Oh awesome to look yet okay look okay
look at this what what it's so seamless
looks so real that was good that was
really good I like this game thank you
hey you're welcome the uterus thing
translation bottom
[Music]
finally I know I could do it okay Danny
DeVito here we go we're gonna get
anything okay
hamster eats a tiny burrito or man eats
tiny hamster why why would you do that
what the [ __ ] oh no what the [ __ ] take
it away why would you do that oh that
actually let me gag really
oh my god why why would he do that
bye did you hear this I thought it was
wedding bag oh just was the hamster in
his dude he chewed in the hamster like
pop Sagan's what's wrong with you oh I
know my poor little my poor that Liars
not here it is again he's got that blue
hair Oh what the [ __ ] it oh I don't know
[Music]
camera one okay Kara what okay oh it's
my time to talk I don't want to puppet
digs a hole or a dude with a hole in his
face please be the puppy please the
puppy
I need the puppy that is not a puppy
Oh what the [ __ ] is he alive it's not a
dude with a hole in his face that's a
dude with half a face yeah bull running
accidents our tree frog croaking frogs
ah see they do that but they don't [ __ ]
afterwards
wouldn't you get a tree frog then a
hamburger
don't make fun of my [ __ ] frog you
laugh oh my god it's my friends is he
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] don't torture look up
his ball ball he thinks it's oh okay
he's reacting tree frogs the natural
enemy of hamburgers final one Jack this
is st. you think you're better than me
yeah whoever wins this welcome everybody
to the yearly bottle flip championship
tournament Sweden vs. our Sweden vs.
iron okay
Sweden starts never mind
this ain't gonna be the first to warm
[ __ ] I'm so close every time though this
bottle is [ __ ]
I am the one okay
No yeah okay continues and continues
[Applause]
come on
why I'm the one come on
Sweden Sweden Sweden the pressure is so
much
this is ridiculous from
yes for sweet this finale is killing me
this is it
[Music]
I am the best bottle flipper yes Lerman
Jack septic well now we know who the
best bottle flipper is now it's
punishment I'm gonna let you watch my
least favorite video in the whole world
[Music]
there you go enjoy okay bye he's so loud
what's wrong with him alright well thank
you jack for June the bottle flavor
challenge no problem let's not call it
that yeah check out jack if you for some
reason don't know who he is I'm Lincoln
yeah it's not like I'm a [ __ ] mean I
already played wait that was a person
there's a play button with my name on it
can I just get to see you with it there
you go as a loser of the Bible just flip
challenge you get this going plain I
don't want this this is yours now leave
a like if you enjoyed and I'll see you
bro brofist Jack septic play button face
that's I've always waited for that never
mind do it there it is beautiful
[Music]